PRODUCTS LIKE BENAYLPLUS CONGES
MOANTO THE F
THESE PROJECTSENNENELYION IN
DREA
G  R TO SEE FRINPRODUCTS.
WAS HECRER WAS A LIT
ORAL CD RE  POINT HERIN3, WHERE
WE'RE FINALLLOOKING AT THAT G Y
PLACEBO,FOULAS FU VET MEN R RD
DEGREE, TIERS
AC CD . CAN STINA
SPRAY T OTAKANYTHING ORAL.
>>T DRUGBEINRECLASSIFIED AS SUL
S DISCERLEDGMEO  W FOR TPORTION
REMEMBRY.
ERE ARE OVER 250 PRODUCTS,
LE THAT ARE  AND IT WIE VERY
IVE  WHA OING TO DEHOL IMPACT
EN YOU HAVE A LDTOMS, RELATED,R
FLU, OR SOMETHING, TO THDEGREE
THESE PRODUCTS.
RETICENC T TH
INGREDIENT IN THEM.
>> OING VIEW.
WE SHOULD ACTUAL H
CON OU
BETHE ABILITY TO
YO
STAKE, ANDOU KNOW
YEARND GACOW
WEAVATN
COYOHA
T-COUNT
YOU HAVE TK ST .
ITGUANEN THEM,REVEOR DO HAVE VAL
S STILL TH
Y OKAY.ERN, OF URTHIS FALL, AN,
S A W COVID
INE ALKET.T.START
>> IS AVAILABLE W.IN FAC WSATH
SI OF AGAND OLDER.HEND THEM AAN
SPECIALIZED GROUP.
THASTION.ALLYLAE,E GHT OFES.
>>WE WILL SEE IT BE BROAE NOW TU